I have the story from Newsweek and it is
one of the greatest headlines I've ever
seen the fake news publish John
fetterman's question at Senate hearing
leaves witness speechless not in the way
that you think not in the way that
Newsweek would have you believe and this
is exactly it they want you to believe
that his question was so good so strong
that the witness was like how do I have
nothing to say when in reality what
happened was John fetterman didn't say
anything coherent at all he's you play
it sputtering can you play it because
like how much you want to bet they
didn't put it in the article oh my gosh
without question here let's go no I know
but like is it actually going to be in
it they went to go to Hawaii's after
there was a crash of your
it did happen it did happen and that's
in Fortune the second biggest bank in
U.S history collapsed collapsed and
chose to go to Hawaii this isn't the
good part yeah I've never been to Hawaii
I don't think they're going to show it I
think you're right I think they're gonna
or should we crashed a bank you know so
given that this is I'm the last person I
don't have much left to ask but I will
you know let me ask you this one
particular question no I think they're
going to put to everyone here on that
and it is it is an inside is it an
inside joke no no matter how incompetent
or how greedy the government will always
bail you out when your bank crashes I
mean everyone has to know that right you
know everyone has to realize that no
matter no matter how bad I behave no
matter how big my my uh race is my my
bonuses and everything you know we will
come in and bail it because we can't
crash the economy watch the way SV bib
was argued that it was going to crack
what did he just say
I I have no idea I actually that's not
even the crazy part I did a short that's
not the crazy part because I did one
there's a minute and 10 seconds I just
did a commentary for like you know
Facebook and social on it and I'll do it
on the podcast tomorrow I guess like but
it's a it's a minute and 10 seconds of
utter insanity and like Federman you
know I I've spent a lot of time on this
one because I'm one of the few guys I've
been called uh you know not a racist on
John fetterman but I was called an
ableist because I went after him which
is them admitting he's disabled by the
way exactly well for those of you who
don't know that means you discriminate
against those with disabilities and I
just don't think it's ever going to be
popular with the American people to not
expect basic cognitive function from a
United States Senator this is someone
who could vote to send your children to
war it's someone who's voting on
trillions of dollars and will and he'll
rubber stamp the Democrat thing do you
have the actual quote Yeah you want to
play yeah yeah play it it's just too
good
staggering responsive responsibility
that the the head of a bank could
literally could literally crash our
economy
astonishing that's like if you have I
mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in the
guaranteed a guaranteed way to be saved
by again by no matter no matter how you
know so it's it's you know isn't it
appropriate that the those kinds of this
kind of control should be more stricter
speechless prevent this kind of thing
from going or should we just go on and
start bailing and sailing whoever Bank
regardless of how however there's
however conduct is
it's like when you're trying to talk to
a girl you like you know you get nervous
I love how his look at the guy's like oh
he can't respond I'm like because you're
an embassy
a requirements you know for a a a a
hungry family has to to have these this
kind of penalties or these some kinds of
word working uh required shouldn't you
have a working requirement after we sell
your bank with billions of your bank
because they see me more preoccupied uh
when then snap uh then the requirements
for works for Hungry people but not
about protecting the tax the tax papers
you know that will fail no matter
whatever does about a bank to crash it
what
the media when he got elected the media
was happy to say hey this is a guy that
could be for 2024 I mean I mean now we
have an imbecile in office right now so
like exactly why should we hold itself
or do a higher standard than the
president but I want everybody to
remember what you just heard from this
man and I want to show it what Newsweek
wrote yes here's here's what music
writes quote Republicans want a work
requirement for SNAP for Hungry families
shouldn't you have a working requirement
after we bail out your bank fetterman
asked the at the end of the hearing he
does that those were not the words
not even a little bit those words The
Washington Post did the same thing uh
where they he the guy I guess did a
correction well yesterday I tweeted a
quote provided to me by the Senator's
office without checking it against the
video because he gave this glowing quote
that actually made sense I don't
necessarily agree with you know what was
in there but it's what they wrote it
flowed it's what they wrote like and
they're just covering it and again I I
know they'll call me an ableist once
again but I do not think it's
unreasonable for the American public the
voting public to expect basic cognitive
function this is a United States Senator
guys like this is not someone you know
and I don't I don't think you led Joe
Biden do it either but like you wouldn't
let this guy drive you in an Uber car
like yeah you certainly why it gets lost
on stage and is confused there is
something sad about it because he is so
pathetic in that well that's that
honestly that's the hard part that's why
I think it was easy to get people to
hate Hillary it's hard though it's hard
to hate your body like whether the
corrupt like you look at him you can't
if you're human you can't help but feel
bad for a minute because you realize he
has no idea where he is it's the same
thing he's so clearly trying to recall I
mean a lot of officials memorize their
statement that they're going to have
that's not unusual but he is struggling
so desperately to recall what he is
supposed to be saying not just like oh
I'm getting staged right I'm forgetting
my lines like he is not there and in
some ways that is unnerving that there's
a group of people who can see this
person who's clearly sick and suffering
and saying go out there and try and you
know oh and that's right and hit the
talking points he's being used as a pawn
because he's not hated like like a
Hillary was right now I'd argue that
he's probably far more effective in
actually delivering some of the insanity
of the radical left policies because
he'll sign anything you put in front of
him because he does not know where he is
he's also incapable of reasoning about
no no but hear me out no I think you're
right like whoever is in charge whether
it's Obama whether it's Susan Rice
whether it's one of these you know
radicals Obama felt the same way but he
just wasn't going to destroy his legacy
signing this stuff in they're happy to
throw Joe under the bus because like
what's his legacy going to be but
they're actually actually furthering
that Insanity do we really believe that
like an 85 year old Irish Catholic guy
like you know the trans thing it's the
social justice cause of this generation
like I don't know I don't think anyone
believes that but he'll say it like I
certainly don't think an Irish Catholic
believes that stuff well you're
certainly not allowed to yeah but she's
not you're not a real Catholic if you
believe you should transition kids
that's not even a question right that's
not even a rolly question like Catholics
do not believe in transgenderism at all
but he's also pro-abortion and he's also
pro-abortion Joe Biden is not a
practicing Catholic and he hasn't been
for decades because he doesn't give a
cent to church teaching he doesn't
believe in what the Catholic Church
teaches Sheamus is a Shiite wahhabi cat
that's right I can see that but I think
that's like a lot
Americans though a lot of Americans
identify as Christian and don't you know
live out those practices at all it's
because a lot of unidentify as women you
know I know they don't live out those
practices either listen the reality it
seems like we can identify us a lot more
than we we could have a few years ago so
I'm going to give someone who's not
quite 100 practicing Catholic I'm gonna
give them a little bit more slack than
the people who you know are going to
force me to say some sort of pronoun
is a trans Catholic he does identify
fetterman identifies as a senator and
the responses and I know it sounds like
a joke this is not a joke I'm being
serious he runs for the Senate he is not
capable of being a senator I feel bad
for him because you know he really he
always wanted this he has a stroke I I
it's a horrible thing and I feel bad and
now he's still feel you know what's
happening
what I'm trying to get it when I say he
identifies as a senator is much in the
way a leftist will go to someone and say
yes you're exactly what you think you
are they're going to this man and being
like yeah you're a senator you're a
senator stamp it here when he's clearly
incapable he is not he's effective but
the thing and people don't realize that
and they're they've been lying to people
about this they knew this about the
stroke
they could have had Conor lamb who was a
congressman and again I don't agree with
a lot of his positions but at least he's
present you know at least
there's a there's a gerbil in the
hamster wheel like moving around where
it's not with him but they said this is
a guy that we can get him to win it
doesn't matter if he's capable of
thought because all he has to do is
rubber stamp but look Chuck Schumer says
and it also talks about the the issues
with elections now I won't talk about
elections now maybe we'll do it in the
later hour because and again I won't say
anything but like do we really think
that like the people of Pennsylvania
were shown this man and like oh yeah
that's my guy but or do we think there
was a ballot harvesting operation and
there you know there's that uh joke from
I think it was what's the guy's name was
it John Dye I hope I'm getting his name
wrong he said uh why how come when uh if
lizzo is so beautiful how come women get
so mad when I say you look like lizzo
yeah yes it's because she's healthy
they're lying right this is what I mean
the same people who are going to lizzo
and saying oh you're so beautiful are
the people going to John fetterman be
like you're a great Senator Yep they're
not being honest with us because they're
putting the feelings of the individual
who wishes they were healthy beautiful
or a senator in front of the actual
responsibilities of a person in that
position yeah and this is one of the
very sad Paradigm shifts that is leading
to the slow death of the West what
people used to do
is they would encourage you when you
were young to try to figure out what you
could give to the world what is your
vocation what are you meant for what can
you provide to others then it was
shifted towards what can you do for
yourself how can you prove that you're
impressive how can you be in a position
that's comfortable for you and so what
we end up with is a situation where you
have someone who is either in steep
cognitive decline as Joe Biden is but
wanted to be the president or his
handlers wanted him to be the president
and so it's mean to tell him he can't or
someone like John fetterman who is quite
clearly cognitively impaired but who
wants to be a senator and so no one
around him was willing to say Hey you
actually can't do that job I don't even
know that he wants it I don't know to be
fair
I think he was bullied into it they're
like this is our best chance and now
you're gonna sit there for six years and
get through it you don't really have to
show up you could wear shorts on the
floor of the Senate and that your
hoodies you love your sneakers I'm not
one that like overdresses it's not my
like but like I don't know there's still
a respect for that Institution and like
they don't care about that anymore like
that's all gone well let me just add one
caveat to what I'm saying then you you
could very much be right that they
bullied him into this they thought he'd
be someone who could represent their
interests well and I think that's likely
the case even with somebody like Joe
Biden but the American people should be
able to see hey the purpose of a job
isn't to make someone feel special for
having that job the purpose of a job is
to provide something to society this man
cannot provide to us as the people what
a senator is supposed to provide because
he's clearly disabled right he's just
not meant for that position there's
nothing wrong with being disabled it
doesn't make you a bad person there's
nothing wrong in the moral sense right
you're not less valuable as a person but
it does mean there are certain jobs that
aren't open to you because they require
a high degree of confidence yeah I think
what you're but that's mean but that's
mean to say I think that's when you let
him perform brain surgery on you when
you let you know
do you think that she can't do because
he is uh cognitively impaired but I
think we're seeing this happen with Joe
Biden with fetterman and we're seeing it
with Dianne Feinstein in Congress yeah
like she is enough where where Democrats
are openly talking about maybe she
should step down we know she's not going
to seek another term maybe she is not
healthy enough to continue in her job
but instead they're like well she took
three months off and we're going to
welcome her back we're going to pretend
things are fine I mean it is she was
gone three years ago it was known like
it's one of the biggest sort of Untold
secrets of watching I know like they're
like oh yeah she's got dementia like
it's like people in DC people in power
understand that this is the case like
they talk about it but openly they want
to hold on to the seat that's for
everyone around them I mean this was
like the with Ruth Bader Ginsburg right
there was a huge like I think it was
kind of a joke but like that she already
had retired and all of her staff were
writing all of her comments anyways
right like this was something that
people joked about and I think it's the
same thing with with as many people and
in fact in fact if you can have a person
like John fetterman in the senate seat
and get the policy you want through why
wouldn't you pick another candidate who
is easily manipulated right if you're a
Handler and you can't personally hold
public office for whatever reason but
you can find someone who you can
basically pop it and get your policies
through why wouldn't you do that someone
else is taking the blows that you don't
have to absorb but you're getting your
way you're holding on to the power well
I mean it's funny how similar these
politicians are to pop stars today I
mean there's just people behind the
scenes writing all of their material for
them making all of the money off of them
and they're just the face of the
operation and they really do run it like
a franchise once that person is beyond
the point of really being able to
perform they hop them up on performance
enhancing drugs so that they can keep
doing so it's horribly cruel you guys
saw Dianne Feinstein forgot she was gone
right like the big story was that she
said what do you mean I've been here the
whole time and they're like also have
her face appears to be paralyzed
she was out for pneumonia and apparently
we're not gonna talk I wrote about it in
my book uh when I wrote liberal
privilege like Joe Biden's had two brain
aneurysms like if you ask any guy you
know that's a brain surgeon uh you ask a
neurologist about like the statistical
probability of there not being serious
issues with one annual
it's almost like non-existent with two
and then when you see it and you see the
eyes you're look and it's just dead or
hear him talk or you he or you see the
fear even worse when when he when you
know he forgets where he is or can't get
off the stage because it's not just a
little confusion there's actually a
moment of panic and you see it and so do
our enemies and so the people that are
making decisions abroad and you know
it's literally influencing our space on
the world right now because you know
that's the nature of predation right
Predators see weakness uh and they
pounce that's right what they do like
that's that's a story as old as
any living yeah and now Joe Biden is
competing with himself to become our
nation's oldest president and you know
of course your father is is older as
well but I don't really know that we
want to elect our second oldest
president who already gets lost on stage
but Trump's clearly younger cognitively
right like 85 years old that can run
circles around my 40 year old friend
this is a relative thing and I get I'm
not just saying that because my father
but like if you put you sit in a room
with my father it's like okay like you
know he can hold court for three hours
he can go on CNN like could you would
you put Joe Biden on Newsmax oh my gosh
no you can't do that no one would even
watches did you guys hear the audio of
one of the Secret Service members being
like okay we're just gonna walk here and
you're gonna stand on that X like well
he still misses it he's still missing I
think there's a video I could be wrong
so I don't want to get fact checked but
I think there was one way he's like
somewhere a blind guy literally was like
no no you have to come over here they
were a blind man was guiding him and he
still got it wrong like it's a blind
leading The Binding literally yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time